TRUMD YOU DO THAT IF YOU HAD
DONENYTHING?
LET'S GO"N BURNETT.
AP AGREED TOME E CHARGED AFTER
ACCORDING TO AN ATTORNEY
FAMI TE IT
LEAD TO MORE SEVERS
IN THEIO
ATGE BLAMED FOR
JOHNS PUTTG THBL DEADLY
"TRUMP INCITEDHAT BLOO MORE
FORMER REPUBLICAN SPEAKEE BROUG
OF HIS OWN P.
CONGRESSMAN BROO.
SWEAT AND TEARS AND BLOOD AN
CA IT IS THE GREATES
NATION IE WORLD'S HISTORY. QOR
D
COURAGE TO FIGHT FORUTFES VE O
TRUMP IS NOT THENLE TRYING
TO WHIWA THENT SURRECTION DAY
TUCKER CARLSON THINKIN
INSURRECTION WAS NO BIG .>> THE
LO TD EXTREME  MADAI
THE LAST ELECTION WAS NOT FA.
>> DID YOU WATCH WHAT HAPPENED
ATAYOSE WERE NOT THE IDEAS THEY
WE. WE WANT PENCE.
>> WE WANT.RING OUT PENCE.
>> BRING OUT NNA
WHE U,?
>> AND IT WAS NOT JUST TALK.
THADSE THAT THEYARAPITOL GRO
TH DA POLICE OERLED.PO
JU OFFICOS.ANOTHER LOST TGHIN W?
ALL OFSETHE BIG LIE  SOW
T FAIRER CALT B-S. OI CAN'E THER
REPEATING SUCH FACTS THAN
THIS THAT THE ELECTIAS>> W AWARC
AFFECTED THE NTIAL ON.
>> WE HAVEOT SEE
THE PRESS QUT  ANY FRAUD IN TH
>> THREE MONTHS LATER E
STILL PUSHINININ THE ONLY DANGSL
CONSTITUTION
JIM, YOU COVERED FOUR  THE WHITA
ANY LESSONS  IT.
>> OF COURSE.
HE DOET THINK  TO
LEARN ANY LESSONS.
ATY CLEAR OFU ID OUT A FEWENTS.
GETTIN TO WHE DONA
TRUMP, THIS IS SOMEBODY SPEAKING
ON JANUARY AS
POINTING OUT
I TALKED TO S R S A
TRUM ENDORSEIT IS GOIND PEOPLE .
LET'S GO BACK TO THNER'SBOOK.
WHAT'S GOING ON. FSPEAKER SAYSEE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS LOOKING TO
DONAMP
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO SPEAK
AT THE RETREAT ON SATURDAY
MANY OTHER LEADING FIGURES
REPUBLICA
NING PLE, DISRB
MUCH OF THE ICAN
NOT BACKED AWAFROMALUMP.
TH ENABLING DONALD TRUMP.NO, AS
LESSFRANUARY 6th
E PARTY IS M
I WANT TO O MATTHEUD AND VERY
YG WITHT ,
BOEHNER SAYS TRUMPD
ENATE IN 20 H
NL
THING JUST ASK ANY REPUBLICAIN
GEORGIA.
CANDIDATE INPRIMARY
RACE.A CANDIDATE WHO WAS ERTH
THE
ECTION SEAIGNIFICANCE IS TS?
>> TMES A HUGE
PROBLEM.
DONARURESENTTHLEM.Y NAASE E
H BIGGERHINGH THE REPUBLICAN PA
TODAY.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IIC WHER
THGA PARTIES IN AMERICA. ONE
WE HAD OTHER WAL
AND THE INNDY AND
THE NO MOVEMENT AND
HAD WHITE SUPRY AND AR
VER HAVE WE BEEN COMPLETELY
TAKEN OVY?ERICA HAS MANY GRE
THE SOIL OT OF THE
IL OF
SOIL OERD DIFFERENT TODAY IS W
OF THE COURY
POWERFULNG WITH MAJOR
WE NEVER IT BEFORE I
ER>> WE HAM
IT IT. LETK YOU TH
CABLE NETWOR TUCKE
A SMART GUY WITH A GIANT RM AND.
OWY
HETING OUT THERE.
THABOULE.TH RIGHT?E.
W  A T
>> IT IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
I THINISICULAR
BOLDER VISIOT VERY
LO AL
TC
THE ARGUMENT THAT EYO
AEWS AND THEY
D IN AND EY HADENALS INIROM
HAD Z TIES WHWE THEIR WAY TO K
LEGISLATURES.
THOUPS AREEG
TURN ON EACHT
FOT US SEE
WHAT HISTORY INDICY
THESE GROUPSRE I CONNEED
AND THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON OUR
DEMOCRACY.
WE KNOW THAT'S WHAT TH HAVE
BEEN DOING BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT S
AND IF N GATTHth